let's get back to the phones remember
you can get all of your David Pakman
show gear including the new coffee
blends at david pakman.com slash gear
we're taking your calls at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty let's
pick it up with our next caller from the
six one six area code caller what's your
name and where are you calling from hi
this is Bailey from Grand Rapids how's
it going what's on your mind um okay I
actually had two short questions I think
they got to be real short I've got
seventeen people holding right now all
right what are your opinion on anarchist
communism pass no I mean listen I'm not
I'm neither an anarchist nor a communist
I've not studied anarcho-communism
specifically in significant detail I'm
willing to look into it Pat do you have
a strong feeling about anarcho-communism
I would love to see where that falls on
the political spectrum I mean very far
left and then very very libertarian yes
I believe so
so okay let me get back to you on that
one but I'm neither an anarchist nor a
communist and then my second question is
actually waiting for show you did not
too long ago let's flood Trump is doing
causing this chaos distracting from what
the House Republican video how much
damage do you really think they can do
Oh massive and I'm glad you're bringing
this up we once a week I am doing sort
of like a catch you up on while we've
been understandably focused on the fact
that the President may be a Russian
puppet etc etc here's a list of bills
that have either passed the Republican
House or Senate or have passed the House
and are going to the Senate or have been
proposed and the amount of damage I
actually have an even more it's not
really conspiratorial but it's more it
suggests an even more sort of evil
coordination from House Republicans they
may be using the public insanity of what
Trump is doing in to their advantage to
just get a lot of stuff pass repeal
regulations business-friendly regulation
removals climate destroying laws and
Bill's etc I think that there's a lot to
what you're saying and I don't know what
you think Pat but I think Republicans
can do a lot of damage by passing bills
while we're understandably focused on
the constant scandals of the Trump
administration they definitely can I
mean if you look back at 2009-2010 when
Democrats had control of the executive
branch and the legislative branch they
could have done a lot but they wanted to
reach agreement with the other side of
the aisle so relatively speaking they
didn't do much I don't think the
Republicans have those same reservations
whatsoever now absolutely not so yes a
very very good point appreciate the call
appreciate the question and we're we're
going to be reporting on what the
Republicans do in the House and Senate
regardless of what Trump does that you
can take my word for it okay all right
thank you so much appreciate the call